ce que pour les entreprises françaises
il peut y avoir un effet également bon
manque de ces sanctions alors d'une
certaine manière oui parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui sont
exposés il ya 35 entreprises sur les 40
du cac 40 qui sont présentes en russie
au total ce sont même plus de 700
filiales d'entreprises françaises qui
sont présentes en russie en particulier
dans le secteur bancaire la société
générale par exemple dans le secteur de
l'énergie évidemment total énergie dans
le secteur automobile aussi à renault
qui représente tout de même 30 % du
marché automobile russe avec sa marque
dacia ou bien dans le secteur
agroalimentaire mais et tout cela est à
relativiser d'ailleurs ce matin l'un des
patrons de ces grands groupes le groupe
le padfone le patron du groupe safran
relativiser tout de même son exposition
en russe il était l'invité de nos
confrères de bfm business on peu
d'écouté
la russie produit globalement environ
30% des besoins mondiaux de titane pour
l'aéronautique donc c'est effectivement
un fournisseur important ce n'est pas le
seul on a d'autres sources donc pour
nous chez safran c'est moins de 50% de
nos approvisionnements le titane mais
quand même voilà donc on a on a
constitué des stocks depuis le début de
l'année à remonter nos stocks donc ça
nous permet de voir jusqu'au mois de
juin au mois d'octobre et puis on va
accélérer avec d'autres sources alors le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire à
lui révélé ce matin que la russie
n'était pas un brin marché stratégique
pour la france et c'est vrai ils ne
représentent qu'un peu plus de 6
milliards d'euros d'exportations ça fait
1,3 pour cent seulement des exportations
françaises et la russie n'est que le 15e
marché de la france à l'export donc
c'est parce qu'ils sont un peu plus
exposé me gonelle de manière globale les
européens disent que c'est pas le marché
le plus important est effectivement
l'allemagne ou l'italie on en parlait
qu'ils sont plus exposés mais vous voyez
sur le sommet sur le gaz et le pétrole
sur le voit il son prix dépendent
beaucoup plus du gallia l'autriche aussi
qu'ils dépensent quasiment à 100 % du
gaz russe mais
mais tous ces pays sont prêts à prendre
le risque tout de même avec cette limite
ne pas aller dans l'autriche pour le
moment même si l'option comme disait
viser à crissier mineurs restent sur la
table merci beaucoup christophe dans
cette merci m